we're going to build an app which allows
you to update your status using only
emoji
and you can see the emoji status of
everyone else using the app
we'll be wiring up several core firebase
components
including authentication cloud functions
and firestore
so you can take what you learn here and
apply it to pretty much anything else
that you're building
[Music]
the app we're building in this series i
think is really cute it's called emoji
status
and it combines a bunch of really
important firebase services in a nice
package
the idea of the app is that we can use
emoji to broadcast
a status or a story emojis are unicode
characters
and they've become really popular as a
means of communication in the past few
years because
more and more phones are able to render
them properly
in this video i'll go through the app in
a bit more detail
i'll talk about the architecture and
then we'll actually start coding in the
next video
i'm also planning on publishing this app
which is super exciting and so i'll
leave a link for that when it gets
approved
in the description right below the like
button
i have the app running here in the
emulator and the only way that we allow
the user to create an account or sign
into their
account on emoji status is through
google and because i've already
previously authenticated via google i'm
able to hit that button automatically go
into the main
screen of our application and in fact we
only really have the login screen and
main screen so this is pretty much all
there is
and i've signed in as myself rahul
pandey and
what you're seeing here is my status my
most recent updated status
along with the most recent status for
every other user in the app
and what you can look in up here in the
menu is i can log out
or i can actually update my status so
let's say i want to update it
to i'm playing uh you know basketball
and i'm not doing so hot so i'm crying
about it
tap okay and then that update gets sent
immediately
to firestore which gets shown in our
recycler view over here
the other cool thing about this is that
as soon as anyone in the app
updates their status that will also be
immediately reflected in our app for
example my friend branner branner bispus
he's actually been making some banana
bread and so let's say that he updates
his status
and right away as soon as he published
it it got updated
on our end in the emulator here
we're going to build exactly this the
published version of the app has a few
extra features which i'm happy to walk
through if people are interested
but the only other thing i want to do in
this video is walk through the
architecture and how the pieces fit
together
like i mentioned in the intro there are
three firebase services that we'll use
to power
our emoji status app first is firebase
authentication for signing and sending
out of our app
next is firebase cloud functions which
allows us to execute code on a server
some javascript code on the server
whenever an event happens in our app
and then third is cloud firestore which
is essentially the database for our app
and so hopefully in the next few minutes
you'll see how these different pieces
fit together
the first is firebase authentication
users need an identity
in your app basically any meaningful app
is going to want to associate the data
that the user creates in the app
to some sort of server or some data in
the cloud
just so that if i wipe the data on my
phone or if i get a new phone
and when i sign into the app i expect my
experience to be
similar to what it was before and so for
that you need to have some way
of creating a unique identity for your
user
there are three broad options for
logging in at least as presented from
the
firebase authentication tool one is you
can allow the user to sign up
by email and password second you can use
a federated identity
provider for example google facebook
twitter github
etc or third you can use phone number
sign up
and we're gonna be talking about the
federated identity provider and in
particular we're going to be allowing
users to
sign into the app using google and the
reason i prefer
this method is because with email
password no one wants to remember
another password right
so typically if you already are signed
into google or facebook it's the easiest
way to get people into your app
and the second thing is that the use of
google
sign-in or facebook sign-in allows us to
bootstrap the user profile we get
information about the user that we
probably wouldn't have gotten
with the phone number sign up approach
or email password sign up approach and
in particular what i'm talking about
is the display name of the user and the
photo url
of the user so a profile picture and
that kind of makes your app feel more
complete
so one of the annoying things about
firebase authentication is that once you
sign in to the app once you create an
account in the app that user entity
that's created has a fixed
set of properties such as the email name
and photo however if you want to store
anything else about the user for example
in our app we want to store
the string of emoji representing that
user status or maybe you could imagine
we want to store the updated time of
that status or any number of
other things that is your responsibility
you have to store other properties on
your own
and that's where cloud firestore comes
in cloud firestore is going to be the
database
which keeps track of the user along with
their status
there's one more annoyance about
firebase authentication which is that
the currently signed in user can only
get information about themselves
but if you think back to the main screen
of our application we want to be able to
query for all the other users
in our application and so in order to do
that we again have to now
every time a user is created in our app
we have to
create a user document or a user entry
in our database in firestore
and store the data for that user
so here's what this will look like we're
going to have firestore we're going to
have
a collection called users and inside of
the user's collection are various
documents each document
represents one user for example here is
brainer bispus my friend and they have a
certain status which is represented by
that
field called emojis
and so this is where firebase cloud
functions comes in
as soon as firebase authentication tells
us that a new user has been
created then we want to trigger a cloud
function to run
to automatically add another document to
the user collection
so in general cloud functions allow us
to run code when certain events are
triggered
and so in our application we're going to
be running some javascript code
when the user account is created and
that is what
is going to be adding to the user's
collection with some default emoji
status which the user can then update
so hopefully now this architecture
diagram makes more sense
we have firebase authentication which is
in charge of signing and signing out
and whenever a new account is created
that's going to
trigger a message to firebase cloud
functions and firebase cloud functions
is then going to create a new user
document which will be
put inside of cloud firestore and that
will get
sent down to our client our android app
which is where it's going to be shown
in the recycler view and if i click on
that edit icon that pencil icon in the
menu and i update my status
that will send a message up to firestore
to say hey i want to update my emoji
status and send that out to all the
other clients as well
so even though there's actually a few
moving pieces here the whole app
is less than 200 lines of code um and
the way i want to
build this out with you is first in the
next video we're going to be building
the login flow
then we're going to create a new user
document with a cloud function so
whenever
the user signs up we're going to create
a new user document
then we're going to implement that list
of users in a recycler view
and we're going to query from firestore
to get that data then we're going to be
allowing the user to update their status
using that edit icon and finally we're
going to restrict the entry of what you
can put in that
edit text to only be emoji
one thing worth mentioning is that i'm
really focusing this series on
how does an android app interact with
all these different firebase services
so the reason the app is less than 200
lines of code is i'm writing almost all
the logic in
the single file main activity.kotlin if
you really wanted to publish this to the
play store
i would recommend breaking things apart
into different files or different
classes just to keep the app more
maintainable
i also would recommend that you have
some familiarity with android you don't
need it but it would definitely help
for understanding if you have done a
little bit of android programming before
if you have any questions or feedback as
you go through it i would love to
connect with you
i'm at rponde1234 on twitter youtube and
linkedin
and finally i wanted to just mention a
big thank you to free code camp
there's a huge transformation in the
world of education going on right now
and i think it's pretty awesome that all
of you are able to learn so much
valuable content through free code camp
and i'm really happy to be part of that
as well
the goal for this video is to allow the
user to create a new account or
sign in to their existing account using
google sign-in with firebase
authentication and once they've signed
in they should navigate to a new screen
which is the main activity
and on that screen they have a menu
option to log out
so what i have here is essentially just
a new project
i call the emoji status app and there
are only two activities so the only
thing i really did after creating the
empty project template
is i added one more activity called
login activity
and login activity is the one where i
added these
intent filters so when you start the app
the first thing that we're seeing
in the emulator here is the login
activity and our goal now is to
integrate firebase authentication and
add a button so that when they hit that
button
and successfully authenticate they'll
navigate to this main activity which
is for now just an empty activity the
first thing we'll do is create a new
firebase project for our application so
go to console.firebase.google.com
and hit this add project button i'll
call this the same as what i called my
project which is emoji status app
hit continue let's disable analytics for
now just because we don't
really care about it and then create
project and this will take
a minute or two to finish all right so
once it's set up hit continue
and we're going to get started with the
android version of this
so the app package name is something
that you set up
when you were creating your project so
for me it's it's this
edu stanford arcade honda followed by
the app name
i'll leave the app nickname blank and
what you need here is a debug signing
certificate sha1
and this is needed because we're going
to be using google sign in so if you hit
this link
then you'll actually see how you can do
it based on your platform i'm on a mac
so what i'm going to do i'm going to
copy
this so i have the terminal open over
here
so i'm going to copy that hit enter and
the default
keystore password is just android
and then here you can actually see print
out the different certificate
fingerprints the one we care about is
the sha one
so i'll copy that now go back to
the setup and paste that in here now we
can register app and then what this is
going to do is it's going to
create the project for us and put all of
the information we need to associate our
android app to firebase
in this googleservices.json so download
that
and then in android studio open up the
project
window the project tool window and we
want to drag the google
googleservices.json
into the app directory so i have over
here i'm going to drag this
into app and i have a confirmation
dialog
hit enter that's good let's go back here
and hit next
all right so in order to add the
firebase software development kit
sdk there are a few modifications we
need to make both at the
project level build.gradle file along
with the
app level build.gradle file so in the
project level
the only one that i found that i need to
add is this one class path copy that
now let's open up android studio and
instead of create all scripts
remember there are two build up gradles
we're going to be modifying initially
the one the project level
and we're going to be adding this line
for the class path google services
now we go back and at the app level
build our griddle file
we're gonna we're gonna add this apply
plug-in line
open up the build.gradle at the app
level
and add that over here and then in the
dependency section this is where we're
going to eventually add
all the libraries for firebase but we're
going to do that later just tap sync now
to make sure that succeeded
cool so now let's hit next and then
let's continue to the console
so i closed all other tabs except for
the console tap on this button here for
go to docs
and we care about android and in
particular if you scroll down
you want authentication go into the
android section
and google sign in so we're going to
follow pretty much this guide over here
the first step is we already did the
first couple here the next thing we need
to do is add the dependencies
for firebase auth so i'm going to copy
that go into the build.gradle
and add it right over here and one thing
is that because we're using kotlin we
can
use the kotlin version of this library
so you just add dash ktx here
and tap on sync now to make sure i
didn't screw anything up
all right looks good and we already did
the shot one fingerprint
and one thing we need to do is in the
firebase console we need to enable
google sign-in so go back
to here go to authentication sign in
method
and we want to enable google sign-in
you need to add in a project support
email
tap on save okay that's enabled now
so one thing you can do here now is open
up the google sign-in to your android
app
but we're going to borrow some pieces
from here
the first thing i want to do actually is
i want to integrate in the sign in
button
into our app this ui so copy that
go into the activity log into xml which
represents the
ui for the login activity
and in the design tab i'm going to just
drag out a text view
into the constraint layout have this be
let's say
100
from the top and it's centered
horizontally that looks good
and let's make the text here say emoji
status
and i want this to be large because it's
the title of our
application so make this display one
maybe
and we'll also update the font let's
make it
sans-serif medium to make it a little
bit darker
cool so now we can go into the code tab
and let's paste in the
xml for that google sign in button
and one thing i want to do is just
update the id to make it more match the
style i like to use in a kotlin app
which is btn sign in
let's see what this is complaining about
this view is not constrained yeah so we
now let's go back into
the design section and figure out how to
constrain it
um i'm gonna import center it
horizontally
this is a little hard to do because
we're not seeing the actual ui here so
first what you should do is build the
app
and this at least should show up in the
ui cool now we see it
and i want the top constraint to be
below the
text view and i wanted to have a margin
let's make it like 32
that looks pretty good cool and so if we
actually run the app now
hopefully we should see the google
sign-in button
awesome then nothing happens when we
click on it which makes sense we need to
add the click listener next
so when the user taps on the button what
we're going to do is launch an intent
to sign in with google and that intent
is going to be created for us
using the google sign-in library so if
we go back to
the guides then go back to the firebase
guide and we're going to copy this
these are options to configure google
sign-in this is the kotlin code tab
so now we're going to go into login
activity in the oncreate method
just paste that in you'll probably need
to import some things
and one thing i'll just help to
demystify a little bit here is that
we have a request id token and we never
defined this string but if you actually
go into the definition click the
definition of here you can see that
we're getting these values xml
the string is coming from google
services so when we integrate the
library
we're getting all of these strings
automatically
so that's one thing one nice thing that
the library takes care of for you
the next thing we need is the google
sign-in client and you can get that by
calling the static method on google sign
in you say dot get client
and you pass in the context and the
options which we just defined
gso so we capture that into a local
variable
called client and now we can
hook up the click listener on the button
so we called the id of that button
button sign in so i'll say btn sign in
dot
set on click listener i wanted to pause
quickly here
because i wanted to explain what you can
do if you are seeing btn sign in
highlighted in red android studio is
complaining that there is no variable
defined btn sign in and the reason you
might be seeing this is because
more recent versions of android studio
have changed how the activity should
reference
views that are defined in the layout
file and so let me show you in a really
simple way how you can fix this
so what you want to do at the top of the
class inside of the activity
you're going to declare a private late
init var
and call it the same as what the
variable is called so in our case it's
btn sign in and it's going to be of type
button
now what you want to do is after the
set content view line in the oncreate
function
we are going to set the value of this
to be find view by id and here we're
going to reference the id
of that view so it'll be r.id.btn sign
in
and now you can see that the red error
went away and we should be able to
proceed
exactly as i'm showing in the tutorial
so as you go through this whole series
anytime you're referencing anything from
the layout file you
you might want to do something like this
just because that will be future proof
regardless of what android studio
version you're on
okay now let's go back to the way i was
doing it in the series but don't get
confused by this
and we're going to create a sign in
intent here
and the intent is coming from the client
dot sign in intent and so now we need to
start an activity
but it's not just starting at activity
we also want to get the result of that
activity did the authentication of
google succeed or fail so that's why
we're going to call start activity for
result
and that requires two parameters one
which is the intent which we just
defined
sign in intent and the second is a
request code which can be kind of any
arbitrary
number so i'm going to define it as a
constant called rc
google sign in and we're going to define
that
inside of a companion object which is
basically a way to hold
all the constants or static variables in
your class so i'll say private
companion object rc sign in and then
this is going to be
private const valve and you can kind of
pick whatever you like i'm going to make
mine 4926
and then one more i'll add is a tag
because we're also going to be logging
some things and the convention
i always use is the tag name is always
the class name
okay so when star activity for result
executes that's going to launch the
google sign in flow
and that flow is going to give us a
response in order to capture that
response we need to
override a method called
onactivityresult in order to help with
that let's go back to the guide
and scroll down a bit and here you can
see the onactivityresult
so i'm going to copy that and
paste it in right below the oncreate
method so right here
and then we called the request code rc
google sign in so i'm going to change
that
and you'll also you're going to have to
import some things
[Music]
well i'm just going to clean this up a
little bit um and basically what's
happening here is that if the
request code of the on activity result
is the same one that we launched with
that means that
we heard back from the google sign in
intent then
the sign in was successful then we're
going to call this method firebase auth
with google so in order to define that
again let's go back to the guide
and here is firebase auth with google so
let's copy that
i'm going to define it as another
function here
and again we're gonna have to import
some things here we need to define the
firebase auth library so again go back
to the guide
and right here um we're gonna have a
late init var
auth at the very top
[Music]
and then this auth is equal to firebase
auth is going to be
how we initialize it that happens in the
oncreate method
let's import firebase auth
and then inside of the oncreate we'll
set it equal
[Music]
and the thing that we skipped over here
on number three is
when the activity starts up the first
thing we want to do is check if these
are signed in because if they're already
signed in we don't want to show them the
login ui we want to show them directly
the main ui so we're going to actually
copy this
so onstart is a lifecycle method on the
activity which happens
after the oncreate so we're going to
execute this and we're going to have
this update ui method
which we can just define create function
update ui
which is takes in a user as a parameter
and we'll fill that in in just a little
bit but going back down here let's
finish off what we were doing here so
now we have the firebase auth defined
they're doing some sort of asynchronous
requests here
to look at the credential and then see
if we can actually
update firebase our project create an
account or sign in to an existing
account
with this credential um i don't want to
use a snack bar
i just want to use a toast so i'm going
to say toast
this and then copy the message
authentication failed
and the length can be short that's fine
and then
that's all we need so if in the success
case we call update ui with
the user in the fail case we call it
with null so we need to be able to
handle the null
firebase user here which is what this
question mark indicates all right so
we're almost done now
um what we want to do in update ui is we
want to actually update the ui which
basically means we want to navigate to
the main activity
i'll leave that as a comment here and
there are two cases here right
one is if the user is null that means we
shouldn't navigate to the main activity
they should try again and figure out how
to log in properly
so in this case we're going to just log
something at warning level and you want
to return early here
otherwise if we've gone past that if
statement that means that we want to
actually go to the main activity and so
in order to do that we say start
activity
and we pass in an intent here and the
intent is going to be um two parameters
one
it's going to be the context the second
parameter is the destination where do we
want the user to end up
and we want the user to end up looking
at the main activity so i'll say main
activity
[Music]
and the last thing i want to do which is
actually a common bug that i've seen
with login uis is that we want to finish
the activity here
and what that means is we don't want
this
login ui to show up in the back stack
once the user has gone to the main
activity
and so by having this line here finished
that means that we're going to
close down the login activity and
that'll make a lot more sense to the
user
if they click back from the next screen
let's try it
all right so i'm going to hit sign in
and i'm going to log in with my personal
account
and let's open up logcat and just see
what happens i'm only going to filter by
login activity
[Music]
and it's okay we can see that we did
call
firebase auth with google with some
token and then we
got a success in the sign in with
credentials which is awesome and so we
did
properly navigate to the main activity
which is where we're seeing hello world
and let's check that this worked by
going into the firebase console
go into authentication and now we do see
that there's one user signed into the
app
great the last thing i want to do in
this video is i would like to add
a menu option in the main activity menu
so that we can actually allow the user
to log out of their account
the way that works is go back into
android studio
and i'm going to create a menu resource
directory so make a new android resource
directory
of type menu and inside of here we're
going to create
a new menu resource file called menu
main
[Music]
and we're going to drag out a menu item
and the title will be log out
and the id can be mi menu item log out
that's all that we need to do from the
menu perspective now we need to tell the
main activity that this is the menu that
you should be
using in the menu bar so go into main
activity
and there's a function here that we want
to override called oncreate
options menu and so here
we're going to say menu inflator this
menu inflator is an attribute on the
contacts so that's why we can just
call it like that we call dot inflate
and you pass in the menu
resource id so it's going to be r dot
menu dot menu main
and the menu which is the parameter that
we pass in right here
and this function returns a boolean so
we're going to return true here
just to indicate that we provided the
menu that should be inflated
now we want to get notified when the
user has tapped on that menu option
for that we're going to call on options
item selected we're going to override
this method
and here the idea is that we're going to
check if the item selected which is the
parameter here
if the id of that is equal to
dot id dot mi logout which is the id we
provided to that log out menu option
in this case i'm going to just log.i log
at info level
that we did log out and this now
requires defining a tag
so let's do that at the top we're gonna
again have a private
companion object with a tag
private cost val tag and we're gonna
have it be
the class name
[Music]
and now we need to simply log out the
user
log out the user in order in order to do
that we're going to do something quite
similar
to login activity in order to retrieve
the firebase authentication
instance so go back into login activity
and remember how we have this late init
var
auth which is a handle on a firebase
auth object
i want to copy that over
and then inside of the oncreate method
we actually initialize it
so oncreate we initialize that
and now all we need to do is call this
method off dot sign out
and once the user has signed out we want
to navigate them back into
the login activity because they have no
business now being in our app in the
main activity right
so i'll say val logout intent
is equal to intent and then same thing
here
we need to have two parameters one which
is the
contacts which is going to be this
referring to the activity and
the destination for where we want the
user to go which is going to be login
activity
[Music]
and one other kind of nuanced bug here
is that
if they do log out we want to clear the
whole back stack right we don't not only
do we not want this main activity to
show up in the back stack
but anything prior to that we also want
to do to dismiss
and so for that there are some flags
that you can set
on the logout intent so i'll say
logoutinintent.flags is equal to
intent dot flag activity new task
or intent flag
activity clear task so with these flags
set on the intent now we can
call start activity with this intent
all right that was a lot let's try it
out and see if it works
i'm going to open up logcat and now
let's look at logs by main activity
which is the
log that we have right here so we should
hopefully
now see a menu option which is great and
it should show
log out so if we tap on that then
hopefully we see the
log out which is great and we do
navigate properly now into
the login ui so that's awesome we now
have the basics of authentication and
sign-in working
in our app using google the next step is
whenever a new user account is created
that's when we want to trigger
the cloud function to run which will
automatically add that user into
firestore
and firestore is what is going to be
powering the
list of users and their emojis in this
view
in the last video we were able to set up
our app to allow the user
to create a new account or sign into
their account using google the fun part
starts in this video
we're going to write some cloud
functions which will automatically
trigger some code to run
every time a new user account is created
and the reason we need to do this
is because we can't store custom
properties such as the emoji status
inside of the same data where
authentication data lives
so we're going to have a separate
collection in firestore
which stores the name of the user along
with the
emoji status and that user is going to
be created
via a cloud function and so the very
first thing i want to do
is inside of our firebase console
we're going to enable cloud firestore
because we're going to have a cloud
function which will
write to cloud firestore so we're going
to create the database here
start it in test mode which basically
means it's less secure but we're
allowing everyone to read and write from
the database as long as
they're within a certain time range so
tap on next and then pick a
firestore location closest to you i'm in
the us so this is the best one for me
tap on enable so now we have our
empty cloud virus store and the idea is
that we're not going to populate
this collection through the client and
instead cloud functions
will add users into a user's collection
that we're going to have
in cloud firestore so the interesting
thing about this
episode of this series is that we're
actually not going to write any android
kotlin code all the cloud functions are
going to be written in javascript
and it's going to be a separate
directory or project altogether
and so don't worry if you're not
experienced with javascript i'm
certainly no expert
but i'll explain things as much as i can
and
it's actually only a few lines of code
so it shouldn't be that difficult
so open up this link for go to the docs
again and actually we can close out the
other tabs
because we don't need to look at the
authentication stuff again
and what we're going to do is now look
at the documentation for
cloud functions and tap on get started
so because we're going to be writing in
javascript we're
going to have to install some new
software in our environment
if you scroll down we already have a
firebase project
and we're going to now set up node.js
and the firebase command line tool
so i already have the firebase tools
installed npm is a node package manager
it's a way
to once you have node
which is a javascript environment then
you can add packages
onto node and so there's a tool called
firebase tools which i already installed
if you don't have that just google for
how to install node or npm
and then come back when when you're done
now what you want to do is
log into firebase and i think i've
already done this but let's check
so tap firebase login
and okay so i'm already logged in this
is my email so that's good
now what you want to do is you want to
create a new
directory which is going to hold your
cloud functions code
so what i did is i went to the same
directory where i had created the
android studio project
and i made a new folder a new directory
in that same parent directory
and i have the same name but i appended
cloud to it this is a brand new
directory
which has nothing in it and so what i'm
going to do here is run this
firebase init functions call
and what this will do is it will prompt
you to set up this
firebase cloud functions project so i'm
going to tap an existing project link it
to an existing firebase project that we
have
and ours is emoji status app
and you can use either javascript or
typescript typescript is basically
a kind of javascript with types
essentially
we're not going to worry about that for
now so just pick javascript do you want
to use
eslint which is basically a linter to
catch probable bugs and
that's always seems like a good thing so
tap on yes and then you want to install
dependencies with npm now
tap on yes we do this will take a second
or two to download all the dependencies
once that's done now if you look at all
the files in this directory
it created a bunch of things for you and
they're kind of documented
over here in the guide and so what i
want to do now is i'm going to open up
this project this directory in vs code
or your editor of choice
so i have the directory opened up in vs
code right over here
and what we're going to do initially
just is uncomment out the starter code
and we'll play around with just this for
the first minute and then we'll
do our trigger based on when a new user
joins our application
what this is doing though is basically
over http which
basically means over the internet when
we receive a request we want to send
back
hello from firebase as a response
one other thing i want to do before we
test that out though is if you scroll
down
you can import the required modules and
initialize an app
and so we're going to copy these bottom
lines over here
but if you go back so we have uh
functions is equal to require base
firebase functions we also want the
firebase admin sdk because this is what
is going to allow us to create a new
user document
when we get that point so just copy that
in and we're going to use that later so
now i want to come back to this
we want to test out this hello world
function
which is uh functions.https basically
being able to respond with this text
whenever
someone hits the corresponding url
endpoint
in order to test this out you can
actually use something called the
firebase
cloud function emulator so we're going
to skip all this
tutorial stuff and just go down here and
here it says
emulate execution of your function so
tap on or
copy and paste this command firebase
emulator to start go into your
terminal well so what this is now saying
is that all
emulators are ready and you can actually
you can see the logs from localhost 4000
so i'm going to
go to that url and here you can see some
of the
ui associated with the emulator i'm
going to go into the log section because
that's the one that we care about
and now i want to actually trigger the
this function to run and the way we can
do that is if you go back again to the
terminal
there should be a url here
so one thing i forgot doing is you have
to actually save this
file index.js and then once you do that
then you should see an output
when you start the emulator for the url
in order to hit
that function which is the https
function so i'm going to copy this
and now if we go into the browser
and hit that url then you can see the
text that we wrote hello from firebase
and if you look over here we can see the
log output
going back to vs code what we're logging
is we're saying hello logs and that's
what you're seeing from the logs right
here
and you're also seeing execution time
but the actual response that we send
back is hello from firebase
and so this is the proof that we are
able to talk to a cloud function at
least
locally the next thing i want to do is
just show
how do you send back an emoji as part of
the response as opposed to just plain
text
and this took a little bit of googling
but it's actually not that hard all you
need to do is
for sending back an emoji as a response
you can say my favorite emoji is and
then you have this backslash u
which is indicating this is a unicode
character and you put in the
code of the unicode so in my case i like
pandas a lot so i'm going to say 1f43c
so now if i go back and hit this url
again
now we see the panda is updated
so the objective now is we want to have
this
a cloud function run when a new user is
created and the way we can do that is we
can say exports
dot and then you can name this function
whatever you want i'm going to call it
add user to firestore
[Music]
and here is where we are going to
indicate to cloud functions that this
function should be
run automatically every time a new user
is created so we say oncreate
[Music]
and this takes in as a parameter the new
user which has just been created
and here is where we define the body of
the function so this code will get run
every time
the new user has been created and the
job here is simply that we want to
add a new document into the user's
collection of firestore with the
information about this user
and so the way this works is we first
get a reference to
the the user so we'll save our user's
ref
the admin dot firestore
dot collection and we're going to create
a new collection if it doesn't exist
already
called users now all we have to do is
return the setting of this new
information
in this user user's collection so the
user's ref
dot doc and the parameter here is we're
creating a new document
with this particular id and the id will
be
the uid of the user who just got created
this user here so i'll say
user dot uid and i want to
call the set method
and inside of set we set the different
parameters
of this new user document so the first
is going to be display name
which is just the display name of the
user which we are getting from google
and second is going to be the list of
emojis which is their status
and so here we have the opportunity to
set a default emoji status for every new
user in our app and so you can kind of
make this whatever you want
what i did is i just picked out three
emojis that i thought were cute
a panda which is the same one from
before a herb emoji
and a heart so basically pandas love
eating plants or bamboo or whatever
so we have this default emojis so now
what we can do is deploy this to the
cloud to
our actual firebase project and then try
creating an account one more time
so in order to deploy this what we can
do is go back to the
documentation and we're
now going to deploy functions to a prod
environment so i'm going to copy this
hit control c to exit out of the local
emulation
and then we're going to say firebase
deploy dash dash only functions
and one thing that you'll notice here as
an error is that we don't have the
proper account setup
to be able to deploy cloud functions we
need to upgrade our plan to be pay as
you go so what you can do is this is
actually pretty easy to update you can
just hit that link
and then right now instead of being on
the spark plan which is free we're going
to modify this to be on the blaze plan
and don't worry it's still actually it's
unless you're using
unless you have a meaningful number of
users in your app this will still be
free
so it really shouldn't matter in terms
of
you having to pay a bunch of money so
i'm just going to go ahead and purchase
it
and if you are concerned you can set a
budget alert so i only want i want to
get alert
alerted as soon as i spend ten dollars
so i say
set budget alert and you can close it
okay so let's try it one more time i'm
gonna rerun the same function
the same command firebase deploy
functions
and so while that's running one thing we
can do is if we go back to our console
the true test of what we just did is if
we create a new user account
that should now trigger a cloud function
and that cloud function should now
show something in cloud firestore so in
order to test that path
we need to actually create a new user so
i'm going to delete the user that we
already have
and then log into our app again and then
that should
trigger this path so i did that i
deleted the user
now it's going to cloud firestore and
when we go back to our app now
let's see if it finished okay so http
error 403 i think this happens under
this because we just upgraded our
account let's try one more time
so going back to the terminal looks like
we did deploy successfully now
so if we go into our running emulator
let's log out
because this user actually doesn't exist
in reality anymore
so now if we sign into the app
let's see if this works but that should
trigger is
a new user being created okay so that
seems like it worked because we were
able to navigate to the main activity so
if i refresh this page we should now see
that user which is me show up okay
that's great
now if we go to cloud firestore and now
we do see
a new user collection user's collection
which is awesome and here we have this
document which is a display name of the
user who just signed in which is me
along with our default emojis it's
amazing
this is a indication that we have this
kind of
end-to-end flow working which involves
authentication cloud functions and
firestore
in the next video our job is to update
this main activity ui
to read from cloud firestore read all
this data and
show it in this screen
in the last video we wrote a few lines
of javascript code so we had some cloud
functions
and basically what this did is every
time a new user was created we added
a new user document into firestore so
now we're done writing all the
javascript that we're going to need for
this app i'm going to exit that
and let's come back to our application
and the idea for this video is we want
to render a recyclerview
which shows the list of all the users in
the app along with their status
and this is simply going to be querying
that user's collection that we just
created and one thing before we actually
start coding is
i want to show you what i did here is i
created some fake
users so basically here's the here's my
actual user
with the default emojis but i also went
ahead and just added a few other
documents to make the app more
interesting
while we don't really have other users
so let me show you what i did i can just
say
auto id the field the first field is
going to be display name
it's going to be of type string and how
we make elon musk
a user for our app and
the second field will be emojis and elon
musk is probably thinking a lot about
cars and rocket ships right so i'm going
to paste in
those two emojis and then tap on save
cool so that added one more user
document to the collection
with the fields that we just declared so
let's go back now to android studio
and inside of main activity we want to
basically have a recycler view here
which fetches that data and displays it
the first thing i want to do is go into
the corresponding layout file for main
activity
we don't need the hello world and
instead i'm going to drag out a
recyclerview
so we're going to add a dependency for
that so tap on ok
that'll take a second or two to finish
and then i'm going to make the
width and height be matched parent
basically i want this recycler view to
take up the whole
screen height i'm going to give this an
id of rv
users go back to main activity
and the idea here is we now want to set
up the recycler view properly with an
adapter and layout manager
so when your data is coming from
firestore as it is in our app
then firebase actually has a really nice
library which makes it a little bit
simpler to set up your recyclerview
and this is the page i have open here so
if you if you google for firebase ui for
android you should be able to find this
page
and this is what we're going to use to
power our recycler view if you want a
refresher on recyclerview and how it
works which will be helpful
to understand what we're doing here i'll
leave a pointer for
a video i created about that topic in
the description
so using this uh library all we need to
do is
we're going to add a dependency here for
using firebase ui with cloud firestore
so copy that let's go into android
studio and open up the
build.gradle file which is in the app
module paste that
tap on sync now
and now what you should do is hit the
link for firebase ui for cloud firestore
and the first thing we need like most
other recycler apps need
is a model what is the data we're trying
to render in each
row or each element of the recyclerview
and the data we're trying to
render is one user so we're going to
have a data class in kotlin
which represents a user object so
ideally this really should be its own
class but just for the sake of
expediency and kind of to make it all
fit together nicely i'm going to
define it right here inside of main
activity so i'm going to define a data
class here
called user and there will be two
attributes on this
user the first is going to be a
um a string which is for the display
name
and one of the things that's important
to note about these data classes is that
if you're trying to map them
with a firestore data object you need to
have a default value for
each element of the data class i'm going
to set this equal to empty string
and then the other attribute is called
emojis
[Music]
is also a string and also has a default
value of empty string
and these names should match up exactly
with whatever you called it
inside of the document over here so make
sure that that's consistent so that that
mapping can happen automatically for you
all right so now we have the model
defined
now we want to actually make a query and
the way the query is going to work is
we're going to have to get an instance
of firestore in our application and then
query on the user's collection and then
if you want to order by something but by
first name for example
or limit it somehow you can do that here
so the first thing we need to do is add
the dependency for firestore on android
so i'm going to use the docs and
let's um make sure you're on the kotlin
tab and we're going to copy this
go into again the app level build.gradle
and tap on sync now
and so the way you reference firestore
is really simple actually you just copy
this
and then you put that at the top of your
class where you want to reference
firestore you have to import this
great so now we have access to firestore
with db
so if we go back to the guide about
firebase ui
here's what the query might look like
this is in java code so if you do a
little bit of translation
so in our case it's going to be val
query is equal to
dv dot collection and then our
collection is called users
and that's actually all i want you can
kind of customize this if you want but
for now i just want to get all the users
in that collection
[Music]
so the next thing is we now need to set
some firestore recycler options
parameterized by the
data and this will take in the
query and then we're going to call the
build method this is a builder class and
we call dot bill to actually get an
instance of this
so i'll call val
[Music]
options is equal to fire store
recycler options
[Music]
import that builder and this is again
parameterized by the data class so i'll
say user
and then we have to set the query
so in set query it takes in two
parameters one which is actual query
and second is the data that you expect
to get from that query in an hour
case we expect to get a list of users so
we're going to specify
here user class.java and one really
important point here is that you need to
specify
a lifecycle owner basically you need to
tell firestore
when should this query be active and
when should it stop
and the way we do that is by setting a
lifecycle owner
is going to be the activity like the the
parent class and so to reference that
we'll just say
this and then we call build
so the next thing we need is an adapter
for the recycler view
and the adapter is responsible for
telling us how can we take the data that
we have
and bind it to a view which is going to
be shown
in the ui if you scroll down here
you can kind of take a look at what an
adapter might look like
so going back to the code what i'm going
to write here
is a val adapter is equal to
and we're going to create a subclass of
the parent
class firestore recycler adapter
and just implement the methods inline
again if if we were kind of doing this
in a more proper way i would actually
recommend exporting this into a separate
class
but just for the sake of kind of keeping
things simple i'm defining both the data
class
and the recycler view adapter right here
in line
so i'll just say object which means i'm
going to create a
instance of this class say firestore
recycler adapter
import that and then this is
parameterized by by two things one which
is a type and that's going to be user
and then second we need a view holder
and this view holder is an object which
holds on to
each view of the recycler view so one
row of the recycler view essentially
and we're going to define that we're
going to call it user view holder
[Music]
and then this is going to take in
options and then we actually
have to implement methods here so first
let's define userviewholder
and userviewholder is simply going to
just be a subclass
of the recyclerview viewholder so i'm
going to define that up here class
userviewholder
is a subclass of recyclerview.viewholder
[Music]
viewholder and then we need to add the
constructor parameter which interstudio
will do for us
okay cool so now we've
defined that um so now
the subclass of firestore cycle adapter
has to implement
certain methods and that's what this is
complaining about so just tap this
on implement methods implement methods
helper
and there are two methods we need to
override so select both of them
and the job here is in
oncreateviewholder we need to
use a layout inflator to create a new
view
and on bind view holder we need to take
the data at this position and bind it
into this view holder
again to really make this expedient and
quick i'm going to use a built-in
android layout for the concrete view
holder and if you wanted to customize
the layout at all then
you should create your own layout but
just to keep things simple there's an
inbuilt one that
will fit our needs so i'm going to say
layout inflator
dot from and we need to pass in a
context here so i'm going to pass in
this at main activity which is
referencing the activity and then
inflate
and here's the inbuilt layout that we're
going to use it's going to be a
two text view layout
android.r android.layout.simple list
item2
then the next parameter is the parent
which is the parameter that was passed
in
and finally attached to root we're going
to pass in false here because the
recyclerview will take care of attaching
it or
detaching it so capture that into a
return value called view
and then we're going to return a new
view holder and the view holder takes in
as a parameter if you remember from up
here
the view holder takes it as a parameter
of view and so we're going to return
here
a new view holder it's a new user view
holder with that
view and then finally we need to now
bind the data
so there are two text views as part of
this
inbuilt layout let me show you if i go
to the definition here
let me only look at the code tab so this
is a two line list item
and there's basically a text view here
which is a little bit larger
and then there's another one which has
an id of text two which is a little bit
smaller
so going back into main activity we're
going to grab references
to these two text views so val tv name
is going to be the top one
and this is going to be a text view
is going to be um inside of the
view from the view holder we're going to
find a view by the id
which is the one that we just looked at
android r dot id
dot text one then there's one more which
is text
2 and this is going to be the textview
where we're going to place all the
emojis
so now in terms of binding the data
properly all we need to do is
in the text view for the name we need to
set the text attribute to be
the name of the user so we actually have
that
passed in as a parameter here uh called
model so i'll say model dot
display name and then for the text view
for the emojis
we again are going to call the other
attribute on the user model
the model.emojis this should be tv
emojis.text
all right that's pretty much it so now
all we have to do is let's use the
adapter
at in reference to the recycler view so
we called the recyclerview
we had we gave an id of rv users so i'm
going to say rvusers.adapter is equal to
adapter
and the very last step is when you set a
layout manager on the
recycler view let's say linear layout
manager
[Music]
import that and linear layout manager
takes in one parameter
at least the version that we're using
which is a contact so i'll pass them
this
okay moment of truth let's see if this
works we just wrote a lot of code
to open up the emulator and hopefully
now because we
um are passing this query into the
adapter it should automatically fetch
the data
and show it all right so that didn't
work and
it turns out that the reason was
actually because
i wasn't properly adding in the internet
permission so what we can do is go into
the manifest file
and start typing user's permission and
the very first recommendation here is
you need internet permission
so now that we've done that let's go
back and run the app one more time
okay and now you can see that we do get
this data back
so all of the information from
cloud firestore is here and then one
thing we can try which is super cool
is if we go over here um and we had
elon musk thinking about the car and the
rocket ship which you can see over here
let's edit this and maybe elon musk is
not thinking about that right now he's
thinking about pretzels
and being happy so
do that an update and immediately you
can see how
in our app elon musk his status got
updated and that's the power of
firestore and
kind of the way we have this set up is
that every time there's a change we're
automatically
instructing the adapter how to query for
the data
we get that and we bind the data
properly so that's one of the things we
get
for free out of the box with this
integration
and the same thing works actually if a
new user is created
so if a new user signs into our app then
we would get a new
document in the user's collection and we
would automatically
get that data sent down to all the
clients who are using
this recyclerview so now we have a way
to see
all the users and their status which is
super cool the next step is we want to
be able to allow users to update their
status right so in the next video we're
going to add one more menu item
which allows the user to write a new
emoji status
and then send it to firestore in the
last video
we built the functionality to allow the
user to read statuses
for themselves and all other users but
there's no way to
allow the user to update their own
status so that's what we're going to fix
in this video
we're going to add one more menu icon
here which is a pencil icon which
indicates that the user can edit it
and modify their status so to get
started let's open up android studio
and go to the menu
main which is what we had added for the
logout option so we're going to add one
more menu item here
and the title of this menu option is
going to be
edit status but no one's actually going
to see the text
because we're going to add an icon so
the id first of all is going to be mi
edit which is menu icon edit and
we're going to add a new icon here so to
do that android 3 is a pretty powerful
way to create your own vector assets
which is
exactly what we're going to use using a
lot of kind of open source
icons so i'm going to go to drawable
right click on it
tap on new vector asset and then
in terms of clip art we're going to
search for something called edit
which is this pencil icon and i'm going
to just call this
ic edit then tap on next
and it'll automatically add it into the
drawable folder
so now that we've added that that'll be
the icon so i'll just start typing
drawable ic edit and one important thing
here is we don't want this to be
buried inside of the overflow menu for
the main activity menu instead we want
it to be shown as an action
so in the show as action tap on always
and tap
apply and so what that did is that it
brought up this menu option
into the top level so if we run the app
now
we can see what this looks like we could
hopefully see one more menu option here
which is the edit pencil icon
awesome so in order to register
something
and do something when this icon is
clicked let's go back into main activity
let me exit a few of these tabs
and in the on options item selected
we're going to have one more condition
here
for if the item id selected is equal to
the one that we just added
r.id.mi edit
and in this case let's add a log
statement just so we know what's
happening
so the objective here is we want to show
a alert dialog
uh which allows the user to update their
status so i'll say show alert dialog
to edit status
and i'm going to delegate the work of
that actually to a method called show
alert dialog
and then this is not defined yet but if
we click on this red light bulb then
android studio will define it for us
and so the way we can create an alert
dialog in android is actually pretty
straightforward
we're going to define a variable called
dialog
and this is going to be we're going to
use the alert dialog builder
this is the builder pattern and i'll say
alert dialog
and then we're going to use the one from
android x appcompat
dot builder and then this takes in the
builder
takes it as a parameter of the contacts
so we'll pass in the activity which is
an example of a context
and then we'll just set various
properties on here for example set title
and the title we'll pass in is update
your emoji
and then another example of what we
want to set on the alert dialog is the
negative button
we'll say cancel and then the listener
we have to pass into the center here
we're going to pass in null
and set positive button
and they'll be okay and again the
listener will be null because we're
going to be attaching
the information about what to do when
this positive button is clicked a little
bit later on
then we'll say dot show
and in order to attach that listener
when the positive button is clicked
that's what we're going to do right here
we'll say dialog dot get button
dialog interface dot
positive button and then set a click
listener
so this code gets executed every time
the positive button is clicked so i'll
just leave a log statement for that
say clicked on positive button
right now you can see that there's no
way for the user to actually
input anything right because we haven't
set up a edit text here but i just want
to show you what this looks like first
so now if i tap on this edit icon you
can see that we have this dialog popup
it says update your emojis and right now
if i
tap on these like the options nothing
really happens
so what we want to do now is actually
have a view show up in that alert dialog
where the user can input their new
status
and so the way this works is you can
have another method on the builder
called set view and we're going to pass
in the edit text here
and i'm actually going to create the
edit text manually
programmatically right here but of
course if you wanted to do something a
little fancier
with having control easy control over
like things like the margin or padding
i'd recommend you actually define an xml
layout file
where you can define the edit text but
just for the sake of expediency
again i'm going to define it right here
so i'll say val
edit text is equal to a new edit text
and then this edit text that we're
creating
in kotlin code takes in uh context
and for now i actually don't want to be
concerned at all about
how do we restrict the input of this
edit text to only be emoji so that'll be
something that we to do
we mark as a to-do for the next video
[Music]
but for now now we have this edit text
so when the user clicks on the
positive button we want to extract the
value out of that edit text
so i'll say edittext.text.2string
and then save that into a variable which
is called
emojis and entered so this is the
what the user desires to update their
status with right this
emoji that they just entered if this
input is blank
which basically means is blank as kind
of a helper function in kotlin
is blank means either is the status
empty
or is it just consisting of white space
so if they said space space space that's
not
something that's valid then we want to
tell the user this is invalid
cannot submit empty text
and then you want to return here
there's one more thing that we need in
order to update the signed in user which
is of course we need to sign in user
right so i'm going to grab the user
current user
and that's coming from the firebase
authentication object
and if the current user is null which it
really shouldn't be because
you only ever see the main activity if
you've logged in from
the the previous activity login activity
but just as a
error handling we should just make sure
that if this is null then we want to
return early again
so i'll copy this toast and just update
the message here
to say no signed in user
let me fix the spelling
[Music]
okay so we'll return early here as well
so here if we've gotten past both of
these
if statements now we want to update the
update firestore with the new emojis
so here what we can do is say
db.collection
on the user's collection we want to find
the corresponding user and the way we do
that we do that
is we find the document which has that
user's id
because if you think back to our cloud
function the document that we created
has the same uid as the user that we
just created
so i'll say currentuser.uid
and we want to now update this user with
certain data
and there are a couple ways you could
input the data here the way i like
which is i think the simplest is you can
just put in pairs of
data so you can say the field path which
is in our case emojis that's what we
call the attribute name
and the value of this key is going to be
emojis entered
and once this is done you can now
dismiss the dialog
[Music]
awesome let's try it so now hopefully we
should see
kind of a very plain edit text in the
alert dialog and when we
tap on the ok button the positive button
we should be able to get the value out
of the edit text and then update
the emoji so
okay i think we built the app properly
if we go back to firestore let's look at
my user and right now i have this panda
herb and heart icon so i'm gonna
update my emojis
with something simple like i'm really in
love
so i have those three and now you can
see it updated here
and also in firestore you can see it got
updated immediately as well
so it seems like that works so the
downside of this is that you know
we're not actually restricting the input
here so i could just say hello
tap okay and actually we do update the
status here to be
hello and it shows up in the app as well
which we don't want we want to restrict
the input of that
edit text to only be emojis so that'll
be the job for the next video
the job for this video is we would like
to be able to restrict the input for
what the user is allowed to enter in the
text view
to only be emoji so right now we're kind
of in a bad state where the user has
entered in hello i've entered in hello
and we actually updated the status as
hello and that defeats the purpose of
the app right the
purpose of the app is to be creative and
and funny with different statuses
that are only consisting of emojis let's
go
to interstudio and fix this we're going
to add some filters
on the edit text so let me show you what
that looks like there's an attribute
here called filters and this basically
is telling the edit text
how can you restrict the input of the
edit text which is exactly
what we want and this filters attribute
will take in an array of filters
i want to point out here that there are
actually two separate filters that we
want to apply
one is the emoji restriction and the
second is a length restriction
so first is the emoji restriction that
one's actually a little bit harder so
i'm going to punt on that for now
i'll get to it in a minute the input
length is actually very simple to
implement
we don't want people to have statuses
which are you know tens or dozens of
characters
long dozens of emojis long instead we
really want to be
concise about how many emojis we're
allowing people to have
and the way we can do that is with the
inbuilt filter called
a length filter so i'll say length
filter is equal to
input filter dot length filter
and here you specify what is the maximum
length that you're allowing
and we're going to allow i'm just going
to put a 9 here and the reason we're
saying 9
is because each emoji is actually a
unicode and a unicode character actually
consists of
multiple characters compared to plain
text so i'm no expert in unicode
but i can leave some pointers to some
documentation but what i found is that
most unicode characters
are at least two characters long or up
to four characters long
and so when i say a max of nine that
essentially means that we're allowing
a maximum of four unicode characters or
potentially as little as two if you got
unlucky and you picked two unicode
characters which
equate to four characters so that's the
first
filter that we're going to apply length
filter the second one we're going to
have
is an emoji filter this is a custom one
that we're going to define
called emoji filter and i'm going to
make a new class out of this emoji
filter
i'm going to define this as a separate
class and again you can sense the
pattern here i'm going to define it
inside of main activity
you should probably be defining this
into a separate class together just for
cleanliness
but just because it'll all fit together
in main activity i'm going to do it
right here
so i'm going to define the inner class
here
called emoji filter this is going to be
a subclass so it's going to inherit
from input filter
[Music]
and you have to override certain methods
here so i'm going to have entertainer
help us with that there's a method here
called filter
and there's a bunch of parameters here
which i'll explain a little bit about
let me put this all in one line just
make it a little bit more readable
but basically the idea here is that
whatever is
attempted to be inputted in the edit
text that is going to be this
source parameter this first parameter
and if we allow this input to be added
to the edit text we're going to simply
return source
so if the added
text is valid return
[Music]
source if it's invalid
then we want to return empty string
basically meaning that whatever you
inputted is not allowed go back to
just empty string so that we essentially
don't modify whatever is already there
in the edit text
and you'll notice here that the return
value of this method is car sequence
and it's valid to return a string here
because a string is actually a type of
car sequence so let me show that to you
if i just type in string
and then i'm able to go to the
definition you can see that the string
class inherits from car sequence
that's why you're allowed to just return
empty string
in certain codepaths okay so hopefully
that makes sense
uh with this pseudocode now the question
is
how can we identify what is valid emoji
based on
this source variable right and the
reason why
source here is a car sequence and not a
car you might think okay i can only
really add one character at a time
in edit text that's actually not
entirely true because
when you have suggestions in the
keyboard on android
you can actually add in certain whole
words and so
the source might be multiple characters
together which is why it's a car
sequence and not just a single car
and similarly an emoji is not one
character it's actually
multiple characters tied together
so the way i want to build this is
actually start with the invalid cases
first
so first of all if source is null
because this is a nullable car sequence
right
or if the source is blank
which basically means that it's just
kind of empty text then i want to return
empty string basically no need to modify
whatever is already in the edit text
[Music]
otherwise i want to just add a log
statement here so i say log
i at info level and then i just want to
kind of help us to debug
what's happening here i'll say added
text source
[Music]
it has a length of let's print out how
long this
car sequence is
[Music]
and now i can just say return source
for now all right so let's just make
sure that we're using this emoji filter
i'm gonna put it inside of the
array of filters and
we're about to finish this to do so i'm
gonna get rid of that as well
okay so let me try the app right now and
just see what happens
based on the logs that we see
let's open up logcat and i'm going to
filter for
main activity
[Music]
okay so if i open up the edit text and i
start
typing t for example so we are able to
add a t
and t like we expect has a length of one
character
however if i start using one of the
autocomplete options such as thanks here
then you can see the added text is the
whatever is remaining after we chop off
the t which is hanks and that has
like the five characters and now let's
actually just go back a little bit
and add in an emoji like like this one
so here you can see this emoji of the
crying face has a length of two
characters
and there are a couple let me see if i
can find one like this one
uh this ribbon emoji has a length of
three characters that's what i was
saying that the
emojis actually have variable lengths
some are two some are three and then
there's a few that are actually four
and so we want to make sure that we
accommodate that scenario
now the question is how do we make sure
that the input is
valid emojis so one thing we can look at
is
is the character that's added have
length of more than one character
but that's not a perfect way of
filtering out only emojis because like
we saw if you add something from the
autocomplete
that will also give you something with
more than one character
and the way we're going to approach this
which i think is the more robust way
is we're going to iterate through each
character of this source
and check the type of it each character
has a type and
what i have found based on some googling
is that every character of an emoji
has a certain type of character and
we're going to check
based on iterating through this car
sequence whether each character
fits that one of those valid types and
so let me just show you what are the
valid types
so i'm going to define a list here
called valid
car types and this is going to be a list
of
and then oh it's going to be character
dot
surrogate these are static variables
defined on the character class
so surrogate is one of them and the
other two i found are
non-spacing mark and character dot other
symbol
these are the three that i found which
encompass what are possible unicode
characters
so turns out i was actually wrong and
there are
a couple other valid character types
that make up emoji
and so i'm going to leave a link to this
just in the description
and here you can see i did a lot more
testing and i found
that there are some emoji characters
which have other character
types and you might want to include this
if you want a more robust way of
checking
for valid emoji and then one thing i
want to do is i want to map this
so right now you can see that these are
all of type byte
and i want to actually make all of these
of type int so this this valid card
types is a list of integer
and the reason i want it to be a list of
integer is because when we
get the type of each input character
from
source it's going to be of type integer
so now our job is simply to iterate
through
each character each input character in
source
and get the type of that that's what i
was referring to as
character dot get type and i'm going to
look at the type of input character
save that into a variable called val
type
and for debugging purposes why don't we
log something here
[Music]
so um
[Music]
character type and then print out the
character type here which is
type
cool and then what we want to do here is
check is this type does it actually
exist
inside of valid character types if the
answer is no
that means that this whatever is being
added is not a valid emoji and we should
not be allowed to add it to that a text
so i'll say if
valid card types contains
um type so if
the list of valid card types doesn't
have type inside of it
that means that you know this is
incorrect this is not valid
so i'll say context is this dot main
activity
only and we'll tell the user only emojis
are allowed
and then return empty string basically
invalidating whatever they've inputted
and just returning empty string
if we've gotten to the end that means
that the
added text is valid and then these other
branches up here
are if this is invalid so let's try it
now
and let's just see what the log
statements tell us about the type of
each character
we'll run this go into the emulator and
let's open up vlogcat
okay so now if i add in t we should
hopefully not be allowed to input that
because it's not of the proper type so
type in t and yeah we do see this toast
message which has only emojis are
allowed
and the edit text is not modified which
is awesome if you look at the logs
you can see that the added text has one
character and the type of this character
is
is uh two and if you look at the
surrogate has type 19 non-spacing mark
is six and other symbols 28. so it's
19 6 and 28. so basically
every character of a unicode should be
one of those and let's test that
right if i now go to the emoji section
and i
do this birthday gift so here you can
see
the birthday gift has two characters and
each are typed surrogate which is this
19
and the other one which had three
characters that ribbon
has the first two characters of type 19
which is surrogate and the last one of
non-spacing mark
this is how we're able to really be able
to distinguish
emojis are valid and things like letters
are not that didn't work and also things
like autocomplete which do have
length of more than one character even
though they're not allowed because
the character type there is not going to
be one of the three that we have put
into the allow list
so now if we go back to the app i tap ok
so now instead of hello we updated the
status and that
it's also updated properly in firestore
so now this is a really good way of
sanitizing the input and only allowing
emoji so if you built out at this point
exactly what we have over here i would
love to hear from you
this is a really kind of cute simple app
which actually integrates a bunch of
firebase services
and if we revisit this initial
architecture diagram hopefully it
all makes a little bit more sense now
firebase authentication will trigger a
function
in firebase cloud functions whenever a
new account is created
that will create the new user document
in the
user's collection and that will get sent
down to all the clients which are
listening
for updates on the user's collection and
finally we just
finished the logic to allow users to
update
their status and that's restricted to
only being emojis
so the cool thing about this is that
there's so many ways you could extend
this and improve this app to make your
own
uh the published version of the app that
i have i did a couple things one is i
improved the ui
and i also added sorting by update time
right because right now
we are whenever you update the status it
just kind of updates in place
but you would like to be able to bring
the users who updated the status most
recently to the very top
of the list so that's something that you
could very easily do just by adding an
updated time attribute
and also you could do other things like
maybe users want the ability to
increase the length of their status and
that could kind of be a premium feature
you could have
have people uh who update their status
frequently get that functionality or it
could be a paid feature there's a bunch
of things that you could kind of
be creative with or experiment with so
if you do any of these i would love to
check out your app and play with it as
well drop me a comment and let me know
that's all i had for this series i hope
you enjoyed building it and you can take
the concepts here and apply it to
whatever else you want to build in the
future
i'll leave links to all the code that we
wrote along with documentation that we
referenced
in the description don't forget to hit
that like button and subscribe
if you have any questions or comments
let me know and i'll help as much as i
can
until next time see you later bye